[Música
] Pagaremos las horas del bebé, supongo. No,
pero algo se sentará bien
.
necesito saber
porque mi soledad cuando no estoy
contigo pierdo la cabeza
en esto
golpéame bebé una vez
más  que no haría para
usar
muéstrame cómo quieres que sea yo bebé
porque necesito saber ahora oh porque mi
soledad me está matando
debo confesar cuando no lo sea será uno
dame bebé
[Música]
está bien el Barón  ¿Cómo se suponía que iba a saber?
Oh cariño, págales, no debí
dejarte ir, oh
[Música]
señorita Scanlon
Oh
[Música]
y dame
cuando no estoy contigo,
la soledad me esta matando así que
dame una
[Música]
que estarás aquí
y dame una señal una vez más
[Música]
[Aplausos]